[Musique]
insulte à sion en nounours au logis
aujourd'hui pour les étudiants en
médecine de saint quentin en yvelines
face à eux deux jeunes patients de 3 à 6
ans qui ont fait le déplacement pour
obtenir des soins pour leurs animaux en
peluche
en fait il est tombé demi et du coup il
s'est passé des nageoires du coup il
peut plus nager et du coup je parte pour
s'occuper de nemo et de ses amis la
ferme de la tramblais à bois d'arcy a
donc été transformé en hôpital pour les
prochains jours elle les étudiants vont
pouvoir apprendre à mieux communiquer
avec les enfants et les enfants vont
dédramatiser le monde médical au cours
d'un véritable parcours de soin de la
salle d'attenté bloc opératoire en
passant par le service radiologie
ils sont assez surprenants parce que
certains ont réponse à tout
il repousse dans nos retranchements et
puis
ils sont pleins d'imagés d'imagination
c'est incroyable 38 faculté de médecine
française se prête à l'exercice
chaque année mais c'est en allemagne que
le projet a été initié dès l'an 2000
angleterre pérou japon roumanie se sont
aussi joints à l'opération
en plus on leur offre un petit un petit
nounours pack donc en fait avec un petit
stéthoscope en plastique enfin tout un
tas de petits goodies des petits
coloriage et tout ça pour se souvenir de
cette journée les enseignants mis à
contribution lors de ces journées feront
le bilan avec les étudiants dans
quelques jours l'occasion de prendre des
nouvelles de leurs patients et de
répondre aux dernières interrogations
des enfants et pour ceux qui
s'inquiéteraient des blessures de nemo
rassurez-vous manon devrait bien prendre
soin de lui et du voir le maître lui
donner des comprimés d'échangés l'autre
par des pansements et banalités
marché